.
LAWRENCE: GOOD EVENING AMERICA
WE STARTED SHOW WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT, DEMOCRATS ARE SOUNDING
ALARM ABOUT HER COUNTRY GROWING
BORDER CRISIS BUT WERE ASKING
HERSELF THE QUESTION, WHAT
CHANGED WITH THE SITUATION, THAT
FINALLY MADE THE LEFT SPEAK UP
FOR NOTHING, ESPECIALLY NOW THE
BORDER CRISIS IS IT A FARAWAY
PROBLEM THAT THEY CAN PLAY OFF
FOR CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS,
WATCH.
>> I CAN'T SAY ANYMORE CLEARLY
WHAT IT MEANS FOR WASHING TO BE
AND SHOULD BE SEEN TO BE A
SANCTUARY CITY.
>> WE HAVE YOUR BACK IN NEW YORK
CITY WE WILL PROTECT YOU, WE
WILL NOT ASK YOUR DOCUMENTATION
STATUS.
>> SAN FRANCISCO STANDS BEHIND
THIS SANCTUARY CITY POLICY.
>> THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN A PLACE
THAT ARE WELCOME TO REFUGEES,
ASYLUM-SEEKERS AND IMMIGRANTS.
>> THIS IS THE CITY FOR 150
YEARS HAS BEEN A CITY OF WELCOME
FOR IMMIGRANTS FROM PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
LAWRENCE: SO PASSIONATE, LIBERAL
SPENT YEARS BRAGGING ABOUT THEIR
CITIES BEING OPEN FOR ILLEGALS,
NOW THEY ARE BEGGING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR AID IN
REINFORCEMENT, THAT IS THE SAME
KIND OF PILL THAT THE BORDER
TOWNS HELD THE ENTIRE STATE OF
TEXAS HAS BEEN ASKING FOR FOR
YEARS, WHEN REPUBLICANS ASK AT
THE BORDER THEY WERE LABELED AS
RACIST, XENOPHOBIC, THEY DIDN'T
SEND THE CAVALRY FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, THIS IS THE LATEST
EXAMPLE OF DEMOCRATS IGNORING
THE ISSUE UNTIL IT FINALLY LANDS
IN THEIR OWN BACKYARD, JUST LAST
WEEK KAMALA HARRIS INSISTED THE
BORDER WAS SECURE.
BUT WHAT IS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE TO SAY NOW
THAT THEY CAN'T IGNORE THIS
CRISIS.
>> WERE COMMITTED TO FIXING THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM INSTEAD OF
WORKING ON SOLUTIONS REPUBLICANS
ARE PLAYING POLITICS WITH HUMAN
BEINGS USING THEM AS PROPS, WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS SIMPLY WRONG
IT'S UN-AMERICAN, IT'S RECKLESS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING
POLITICS WITH HUMAN LIVES, THIS
IS CRUEL WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
DURING THE CRISIS OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND PRETENDED
THE INNOCENT AMERICANS HAVEN'T